Alright Sam, we're going to build an app to manage a music festival.
>> Yes.
>> That seems like a very big problem, managing a
music festival. How, how do you approach a problem that big?
>> I mean there a lot of aspects to a music festival, right? So the easiest
way to go about it would be first to think about it from a high level.
>> Okay, to sort of understand what it means to be a music festival.
>> Exactly. So, break it down into the components we
want to track. Like, we went to a music festival
last weekend. What did we see there?
>> Yeah, it was really interesting because, you know, we were both
there at this same festival, but we were definitely focusing on different
aspects. Like, I was digging the music, the art, the crowds, and
you were paying attention to some things I'd never thought of before.
>> I mean don't get me wrong. I was
definitely paying attention to the music and the crowd
too, and that was awesome. But I was also
really impressed by the overall structure of the event.
>> Right, and
that was something that I had never really considered before.
>> I mean from a logistics point of view, it
was all really pretty impressive. There's so much planning that had
to go into the organizing of multiple stages and bands. I
mean, making sure that everyone would have the right equipment, there
were ticket collectors, security guards, food vendors. I mean, so much
stuff that all had to be planned and managed. So for
now, let's just start small and focus on how to manage
and keep track of one aspect of the festival, the attendees.
>> Right,
because it seems reasonable that a festival manager would want to
keep track of the people going. I'm not sure what, would this
person actually want to track about these attendees. What would they,
how would they do it? so yeah, let's, let's think about it.